ich mag Freiheit und kaum irgendwas
bringt so viel Freiheit wie ein Camper
also ein Van oder Transporter ausgebaut
zu eineer Art Wohnmobil aber eben nicht
von der Stange sondern genauso wie man
sich vorstellt einfach überall Leben und
machen was man will und wo man es will
ohne viel Luxus aber eben doch genug und
eben mit maximaler Freiheit wir planen
an den Projekt jetzt schon seit über
einem Jahr und haben schon vor einem
Jahr nach passenden Autos zum kaufen
gesucht jetzt ist es endlich zu weit
also los geht's dieses Video wird
unterstützt von eoflow von den wir mit
dem gler und Wave 2 ein Kühlschrank und
eine Klimaanlage für den Camper bekommen
haben aber mehr dazu später jetzt kaufen
wir erstmal einen Transporter ja weil
Thomas das letzte Mal den VW Golf
abgeholt hat der ja dann am Ende nicht
mehr so gut
daastand habe ich mir jetzt Auto
geschnappt und schauen wir den Bus
[Musik]
an ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen
soll das Auto war eine komplette
Katastrophe das war ein komplett
hergedängelter Lieferwagen Lackschäden
die ganze Innenverkleidung komplett
zerkratzt also wir waren da jetzt 10
Minuten
da jetzt sind wir wieder gefahren weil
das komplette Katastrophe war der hatte
einfach einen Dieselkanister im Fahrraum
stehen der Schlauch ging dann zu
Standheizung und das war war die Heizung
für dieses Auto hier ich bin gerade
bisschen vom Glauben abgefallen wer wir
uns auf die Suche nach ein neuen Bus
begeben müssen ich habe gerade noch mal
mit einem Verkäufer telefoniert und der
hat einfach das Schätzchen hier auf dem
Hof stehen und jetzt hoffe ich mal dass
der auch so gut ist wie verspricht und
dass es nicht wieder so eine Katastrophe
ist wie beim letzten mal da ist der
Lappen Fahrzeugbrief der Verkäufer super
nett total korrekt bin ich wieder auf
dem Heimweg überbringt Thomas die
fröhliche Nachricht und dann komme ich
nächste Woche mit Thomas noch mal
hierher und hol den Bus ab wir sind
gerade beim Transporter abholen und das
ist richtig geil das ist ja bei einer
Firma die einfach Hamsterräder für für
Katzen macht und ich find ziemlich geil
weil es von der Aufbauart ähnlich wie
meins und schon kann man sein
lieblingsyuber ganz easy anschauen
während man Kalorien verbrennt also ich
find geil weil das sind auch so Viertel
Viertel Bögen die D einfach
zusammengesteckt wurden zu einem ganzen
großen
Kreis man wi haben wir nicht so ein
[Musik]
Lager ja geil zum allerersten Mal sehe
ich jetzt hier den Transporter jetzt
auch schon zu spät we man hat gekauft
der ist schon riesig aber also habe ich
auch so vorgestellt aber ist schon
riesig okay bevor ich jetzt da hinten
reingehe erstmal hier vorne geil okay
also er hat doch drei Sitze hier
brauchen wir noch was dann für Vorhänge
oder so alter das ist ja riesig voll
geil ja perfekt pass mal auf ich geh mal
von hinten rein okay ja du kannst ruhig
Filmen passt holy Shit ist der
hoch ist einfach übel hoch ist das schon
eine Dämmung das ist schon die Dämmung
ja geil also das ist halt krass weil das
das Auto hat schon einige Sachen die ja
gemacht werden müssen aberit die jetzt
auch nicht so spannend sind zu
machen ja let's go oder
oha sogar USB
abgewirkt perfekt alter das ist ja ein
Raumschiff es ist schon bisschen grusig
Alter weil ich bin ja schon halb auf der
Straße und ich sehe immer noch
nichts jo wow also man sitzt schon sehr
hoch es ist auch schon es ist ja einfach
ein Bus
der geht schon ab ja h V gut passt
alles ja da steht er jetzt ne wie lange
war wir
unterwegs 10 Minuten hab vielleicht
schon geschafft man ja also wir chillen
jetzt hier und haben haltc gerufen und
der wird das Ding D noch mal anderthalb
Stunden
Abschleppen
geil ich hoffe einfach mal dass es jetzt
nur eine Kleinigkeit ist die einfach
instant gefixt ist dass wir einfach
direkt mit dem Camper Ausbau weiter
maachen können im schlimmsten Fall ist
natürlich jetzt der Motor wieder kaputt
aber angeblich ist der irgendwie nur 500
km
[Musik]
alt ja ja ja okay wunderbar nee ja dann
äh melden Sie oder halten Sie uns
einfach vom aktuellen Stand das wäre
ganz cool Wiederhören
danke gleichfalls Ciao die melden sich
nie wieder oder ja meinte so die haben
sich bisschen angeschaut schon aber er
hat konkret konnte mir jetzt gar nicht
sagen was ist eigentlich also was
eigentlich los ist also hab die gar
nichts gemacht ja ich besür fast
auch nachdem dann nach drei Wochen
Werkstatt aufentthilt für noch mal 2000
€ vier neue Einspritzdüsen eingebaut
wurden läuft der Braten endlich wieder
inzwischen haben wir übrigens auch schon
den groben Plan und den erzähle ich euch
jetzt zuerst wollten wir eigentlich was
super schlichtes bauen aber nachdem ich
zu viele vanl tiktoks wie dieses hier
gesehen habe habe ich mir egebildet dass
wir so einen geilen Innenausbau auch
brauchen wir wollen also ähnlich wie in
diesem camperausbau hinten drin so ein
Bett das an die Decke fahren kann um
Platz zu machen für die Sitzbank die
drunter ist außerdem eine Küche mit
fließen Wasser und Herd eine Dusche
möglichst mit Warmwasser und natürlich
ein auffen Stauraum wichtig ist aber
auch eine Power Station damit man von
unterwegs arbeiten kann aber natürlich
auch ein Kühlschrank und für warme
Gegende eine Klimaanlage und das alles
hat uns ecofloat zur Verfügung gestellt
den Kühlschrank glacier und die
Klimaanlage Wave 2 haben wir jeweils mit
einem eigenen Akku aber um deren
Laufzeit zu verlängern packen wir noch
die Powerstation ecoflow Delta 2 den
Camper das geile ist dass man die Delta
2 nicht nur per Steckdose aufladen kann
sondern auch über diesen Stecker im Auto
und auch über Solarstrom und das machen
wir als nächstes dafür bauen wir hier
gerade ein balkonkraftwerk von ecoflow
auf bestehend aus 2 x 400 wat
Solarpanels und dem powerstream
mikrowechselrichter womit man Strom ins
Haus einspeisen kann man kann aber auch
die Power Station ecoflow Delta 2
anstecken die den Strom dann je nach
Verbrauch intelligent verteilt die wird
dann aufgeladen während die Sonne
scheint und abends wenn es dunkel ist
und der meiste Strom verbraucht wird
könnt ihr euren Solarstrom nutzen und
spart somit jährlich bis zu 415 € allein
durchs zwischchenpeichern über eine App
könnt ihr den Energieverbrauch
überwachen verwalten und optimieren auch
einzelne Geräte die nicht von ecoflow
sind könnt ihr über smartplugs in
Echtzeit in der App sehen der eoflow
Delta 2 kann auch beim Stromausfall
Strom liefern und man kann ih eben auch
einfach zum Camping mitnehmen den Link
zu den Geräten von ecoflow gibt's in der
Videobeschreibung und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem Camper und als erstes
muss bei dem Camper jetzt hier der Boden
verlegt werden und das Ding ist als wir
den gekauft haben war ja schon Boden
drin ich finde den jetzt nicht so ze von
ze dachte ich aber jetzt mlerweile
gefällen mir eigentlich doch ganz gut
wir schauen jetzt mal zusammen mit
Sophie hi du muss ins Bild
kommen Sophie ob wir den Boden behalten
oder ob wir noch neuen kaufen was
natürlich erstens ohnetig Geld kosten
würde aber zweitens vielleicht einfach
notwendig wä ich bin das erste mal hier
drin ne
oha ist krass oder ja das ist riesig was
sagst ich finde den okay aber ich glaube
dass der auch schon relativ pflegeleicht
ist ne das denke ich auch macht den Sinn
sich mal die anderen Option anzugucken
und dann an dann zu entscheiden wärst Du
kurz dabei mit in den Laden zu fahren ja
gucken kostet erstmal n gucken kostet
erst nichts außer
Zeit der wer auch immer dies dieses Auto
gefahren ist das auf einer Arschbacke
mehr als auf der
anderen also wir haben jetzt einen neuen
Boden gekauft weil der ist
Hal seh das nicht aber die Nacht aber
wir haben den neuen Boden so eingekauft
dass wir den nicht überall hinlegen
sondern nur da wo er halt gebraucht wird
hinten also ungefähr hier wo SP das Bett
drüber kommt ist ja unten dann Lagerraum
da muss jetzt nicht der schönste Boden
sein das da reicht der der hässliche die
Nacht und deswegen verlegen wir den
jetzt einfach überall komplett mal von
hinten nach vorne durch bauen dann hier
die Wände rein bauen die Möbel die das
Pam Pam und am Ende verlegen wir den
schönen Boden hier wenn die Möbel schon
drin sind wahrscheinlich so ungefähr so
ungefähr
[Musik]
machen
so wir haben jetzt die erste Layer da
vorne hingeklebt richtig guck geworden
mega geil hat gar nichts gewählt jetzt
ma
[Musik]
weiter und damit ist der PVC Boden auch
schon verlegt und eigentlich sieht er
doch ganz gut aus jetzt geht's an den
Wänden weiter da bauen wir uns jetzt
erstmal so ein Holzgerüst runter das
hier überall in diesen ganzen Bus
reinkommt als Unterkonstruktion das wir
dann später Platten drauf schrauben
können und schöne Wände haben und dafür
schneiden wir uns jetzt die Latten
[Musik]
zu die Latten jetzt in die Decke kriegen
habe ich mir hier so
ein Hülsen
besorgt
rein Zack und reingenietet haben hier
Gewinde drin wo wir dann später schön
Latten reinschrauben können also der
Decke sind fertig jetzt kümmer ich und
Pascal uns um die Wände dafür nehmen wir
uns jetzt hier die Holzlatten und
spachsen die da einfach in die
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Wand jetzt schon ein Kommentaren Alter
hält von 12 bis Mittag an der Stelle ist
mir dann klar geworden dass ich erstm
einen genauen Plan in 3D anfertig muss
bevor wir weitermachen können und dafür
habe ich einfach den kompletten Bus
eingescannt das hier ist die fertige
Anordnung der Sitzecke die Küche seht
ihr auch dann steht da noch eine Dusche
samt Toilette und ein großer Schrank die
Sitzecke unten soll zwar zu einem
Gästebett unfunktioniert werden können
aber das hauptbett kommt später über die
Sitzecke und soll motorisiert an die
Decke gefahren werden können dann ging
es vor allem darum welches Material
alles bekommen soll und welche Farbe
Sophie und ich haben mit Lederpolstern
experimentiert sind aber dann doch bei
Polstern mit Leinenbezug geblieben ein
großer Teil der Wände soll definitiv
eine Beton Optik bekommen aber halt auch
nicht alles weil sonst die Farbe fehlt
also hatte Sophie die Idee diese
Holzleisten die an der Decke sind auch
in den Runden Wänden einzubauen sieht
cool aus raubt aber wieder wertvollen
Platz also muss was anderes her was
Farbe reinbringt und zwar eine Tapete
sehr gewagt aber ich glaube das wird
cool und jetzt wo wir wissen wie alles
aussehen soll kannst schon weitergehen
mit dem Bau der wänd ich mache jetzt was
was hinterher super viel Sinn macht von
dem ihr aber erstmal nicht raffen werdet
wieso ich es mach ich ma jetzt auf jeden
Fall überall hier in dieses Holz an
einer Seite so eine Nut rein passt
auf
[Musik]
also genau diese Stufe hier habe ich
gemeint und in diese untere Rille die
ich reingefäst habe wird jetzt eine
Holzplatte reingelegt und dann richtig
heftig mit aller Gewalt gebogen bis sie
in die obere Rille einrastet und da
bleibt sie jetzt auch so mittlerweile
ist jetzt fast überall so ein Kasten
drum rum oder irgendwie hier so ein
gestrebe auch hier jetzt sogar an der
Decke dass man quasi jetzt hier bald
eine Verkleidung dran machen kann ein
bisschen fehlt allerdings noch und genau
da geht jetzt weiter so immer ein
bisschen vorbohen ins Blech
und dann hoffen dass die Schraube
hinterer hält oh ja das
warut der auch so ihr kommt
[Musik]
mit die Verkleidung kommt jetzt habe ich
gerade eben schon zugeschnitten dass es
perfekt hier drauf
[Musik]
passt das ist fest jetzt wollte ich
gerade eigentlich das Panel hier
installieren oder halt festschrauben ne
man sieht der Winkel der passt hier aber
nicht und das jetzt exakt nachzumessen
ist gar nicht so leicht deswegen
probiere ich jetzt mal folgendes ich le
mal ein Blatt dran und fah mir einfach
die Kanten hier so nach das sieht schon
mal nicht schlecht aus und jetzt habe
ich das entlang von diesen Linien
einfach noch mal gefaltet und leg wier
drüber und versuch das auch
nachzen so jetzt passt es hoffentlich
hier irgendwie rein ich muss
herausfinden wie genau nee so rum auf
jeden Fall schon mal nicht so rum
sieht's doch ganz gut aus ich weiß nicht
was ich d halten soll dass es Hal
einfach schief ist und dass ich bewusst
schief mach damit die reinpassen ja z
sch ich dran was auch noch passieren
muss ist die Kabel die müssen hinter der
Verkleidung sein ich nicht davor so top
also so langsam wird was so ich würde
sagen wir machen noch mal einen kleinen
Zwischenstand zur Planung da soll ja die
Küche hin da an die Decke soll das Bett
so hoch und runter schiebbar sein hier
hinten in die Ecke kommt eine Dusche da
kommt ein fter Schrank und hier so
Uförmig soll quasi die Sitzecke sein
also ungefähr 2,30 m hier lang 2,30 m
hier lang jeweils natürlich mit dem
Deckel dass man hier schönen Stauraum
reinkriegen kann hier übrigens die
Technik und um diese Sitzbank kümmer wir
uns jetzt hierher da wo später quasi die
Küche in der Nähe ist soll übrigens
unser Kühlschrank der ecoflow
glaer die erste 3 in1 Kühltruhe mit
Gefrierbox und
eiswürfelmaker der kühlt seine 38 lieg
super schnell und hier passen einfach 60
sperdosen rein der gleich hält bis zu 40
Stunden mit seem Akku der rausnehmbar
ist und dann als mega Powerbank
funktioniert mit 100 wat Output auch den
kühlschrankakku könnt ihr schnell
aufladen z. mit den Solarpanels von
ecoflow oder im Auto und natürlich auch
über Steckdose so wir bauen jetzt die
Sitzbank dafür musst du leider noch mal
kurz raus für die Sitzb haben wir wieder
so Latten am Start aber nicht diese
ungehobelten raauen sondern frisch
gekauft richtig schön glatte gehobelte
Latten und daraus machen wir jetzt
irgendwie Möbel 17 € für die hier 17 €
für so ein Ding ja wir haben 800 €
ausgegeben im Baumarkt
insgesamt okay pass auf das eine Mitte
muss er 60 haben ne ja die Aussparung in
der Mitte wir können mit den Kästen hier
so
[Musik]
anfangen jetzt komm nächste in die
Wand jetzt schauen wir dass die beiden
hier Fluchten nehmen mal eine Latte und
wir gehen davon aus dass die gerade ist
oder also wenn nicht dann ist der Boden
vom W nicht
gerade ich glaub tatsächlich dass die
Latte nicht gerade ich glaube die ist
nicht gerade mal was
anderes dann rein
[Musik]
da es ist 60,5 auf den Millimeter genau
es ist wirklich glaube ich das
toleranzmäßig am besten Beste was hier
in dem W bis jetzt gebaut wurde also und
das ist auch das einzige was hier
parallel ist also wirk alle einzige am
ganzen wen die beiden Dinger
zueinander also wir wollen jetzt messen
wie parallel das ist unten haben wir
hier 60,6 ja und oben
60,7 oha okay das ist natürlich schon
schlecht Millimeter Toleranz ist nicht
akzeptabel dann machen wir normal machen
wir das immer besser geil al im ganzen
Ding ist nicht so genau wie diese
Parallelität ja und den rechten Winkel
haben wir jetzt auch direkt mal
demonstrativ eingeklebt damit man das
morgen bewundern
kann das gefällt mir doch was ich hier
sehe ich habe mich anfangs beschwert
dass hier ungefähr alles
freiformmäßig alles total rund ohne
jeglichen Winkel ist und da gefällt mir
doch was ich hier sehe
mega richtig gut weil wo ich die käen
für die radkastenabdeckung gebaut habe
da war nichts im Winkel jede Platte
musste einzeln mit Winkeln zugesägt
werden da bereitet mir der Anblick schon
echt
[Musik]
Freude so ich zeig hier mal ein
Fortschritt die Dinger mittlerweile in
der Verkleidung aus Pappel und hier ist
das heftigste die Küche die ist jetzt
schon relativ weit genau die hat hier
sogar eine kleine Ecke dass man hier
bisschen leichter reinkommt die Küche in
Winkel zu machen ja dass hier alles 90°
hat und so damit später die Schubläden
funktionieren ist eine extreme Challenge
weil in diesem W nichts 90° Winkel hat
und sogar der Boden ist leicht gewölbt
also das na ja ewig gedauert jetzt uns
ist aufgefallen dass bevor wir die Küche
jetzt hier weitermachen können sieht
wunderschön aus wir erst die Verkleidung
von der Tür machen müssen und das ist
super aufwendig und deswegen haben uns
überlegt machen was anderes wir haben ja
hier diese gewölbten Holzplatten und das
Problem ist wir haben die beiden
getrennt voneinander reingemacht ja also
auf der Seite haben wir die festgeklebt
das heißt hier sind die dahinter mit
einer Platte noch mal verleimt das heißt
die sind bomben fest aneinander aber
hier da ist halt hopfum als komplett
verloren ne also das ist halt da ist gar
nichts mehr fest das muss es aber
eigentlich sein weil natürlich die
Tapete drüber kommt und wenn diese
Holzplatten sich verschieben und
verbiegen reißt die halt irgendwann und
das wollen wir natürlich nie so und
jetzt habe ich die komplett
vercrackteste Idee überhaupt gehabt also
das der größte Pfusch überhaupt wie wir
das noch fixen kann jetzt das ist
komplett genial was ich jetzt habe an
Idee habe ja
boah so das ist alles Spachtelmasse das
rausgekommen ist ma noch ein zweites
Loch ma jetzt mal diese todeswaffe
Weg jetzt brauchen wir nämlich gleich
wieder normale schrauben
[Musik]
also das si auf J aus wie ein Smiley der
sehr schwer beeindruckt ist so das wird
jetzt logistisch schwierig wir Zeit den
hammerolen
[Musik]
Alter
nice mussen auch draufsetzen können
deswegen haben wir hier jetzt diese
bambusplatten
zugeschnitten
schneidert also die hier alle sollen
natürlich so klappbar sein dass man
später hier richtig gut staurum haben
wird aber hier kann man es schwierig
klappbar machen weil ja hier diese
Aussparung da drum ja dachte ich mir man
macht die Klappe einfach eher so hier
und den schraubt man fest oben drauf
eigentlich kN man den so hoch klappbar
machen ne ich glaube wir haben eine
Planänderung gemacht wir machen den auch
klappbar aber in die Richtung okay ze
gerade hier ein Schablone die leuch
Scharnier an
und da komm jetzt ein Scharnier rein so
hier kommen jetzt so eine ja Aufnahme
[Musik]
drunter und das setz wir rein ma mal
Drop Test pass auf weil eigentlich
sollten die Dinger ja jetzt Hof sein
aber das ein
Tonne ja so wir versuchen jetzt hier die
Bambusplatte reinzulegen weil die sollte
ja eigentlich genau dazwischen
reinpassen ich nehme die mal hier also
wir müssen das noch ein bisschen hier
die müss noch mal abgesägt werden dann
soll eigentlich passen aber so ist die
Idee ne dass man hier quasi dann den
Tisch einmal aufklappt und dann noch mal
hier so eine übelette liegebank hat oder
eigentlich ein Bett ne man kannz auch
bnen und damit haben wir jetzt richtig
geile klappen mit hier jeder Menge
Stauraum dann hier unserem Kühlschrank
so und hier also hier kommt jetzt die
Klimaanlage rein und zwar die ecoflow
Wave 2 die bisser leistungsstärkste
kompakteste Klimaanlage mit halsfunktion
auf dem Markt in 5 Minuten kann die die
Temperatur in dem kämfer um 10° senken
oder erhöhen einfach nur Lüften geht
auch und gesteuert wird das Ganze weder
am Gerät oder über dieselbe App mit der
man auch das balkonkraftwerk und den
Kühlschrank überwachen und steuern kann
kompakte und ausziehbare Schläuche für
die Abluft sind auch schon
dabei und die Zusatzbatterie die es
separat zu kaufen gibt ist austauschbar
und kann die Klimaanlage bis zu 8
Stunden kabellos betreiben also perfekt
für Zelte und Wohnmobile aber natürlich
auch Innenräume jetzt kann natürlich die
Abluft über den Schlauch ja einfach fürs
Dachfenster rausmachen aber wir machen
das Leben schwer das Teil hier kommt von
außen drauf und von innen kommt D so ein
3D gedruckter Adapter drauf wo man den
Kollegen einfach so zack reindringt kann
so aber wie ihr seht hier fehlt noch ein
Loch und das machen wir jetzt und mit
ein Sicherheit grenzenwahrscheinlichkeit
funktioniert das nicht hiermit das ist
ein eine Lochsäge für Holz eigentlich so
und warum das Teil überhaupt legal auf
dem Markt erwertbar ist weiß ich auch
nicht aber ich werde auf jeden Fall eine
schutzbrillef anziehen und ich habe mich
auch gefragt sollen wir jetzt von außen
nach innen gehen aber dann dachte ich
mir am Ende kommt man dann irgendwie an
der falschen Stelle raus und geh von
innen nach außen das wird schon
irgendwie funktionieren oder auch
nicht so also wir sind schon mal durch
bleich durch mit der Zentrierspitze hier
also eigentlich kann ich jetzt von außen
reingehen jetzt Zen wir rein
[Musik]
Loch drin ist krass und da kommt jetzt
er hier rein und der passt sogar sieht
sogar von außen gut aus so jetzt nennt
mich verrückt die meisten würdenrecht
hier reinschrauben aber ich werde so
machen weil dann hält das nämlich nicht
nur das Wasser das in Form von Regen von
oben kommt sondern auch auf der Autobahn
wenn du fährst in
[Musik]
Fahrtrichtung und damit hat unsere
Klimaanlage auch Abluft bzw aktuell
Heizung was dra bisschen kalt ist und
nach draußen ist super solide was ich
ziemlich gut finde weil es das erste Mal
ist dass ich irgendwie durch so ein
autoblech Karosserie Ding
durchgeschnitten habe und das hat sich
falsch angefühlt hier kommen jetzt die
von balkonkraftwerk vollgeladene Delta 2
rein womit wir hier drin jetzt dank
ecoflow Strom haben die Luft ist
angenehm warm oder wenn man sie eher
kalt haben will dann ist angenehm kühl
genauso wie die Getränke hier im
Kühlschrank kühl sind den Link zu eoflow
gibt's in der Videobeschreibung und
damit war's das von Part 1 wir haben die
komplette Verkleidung gemacht und es hat
ewig gedauert aber noch geiler ist
natürlich das was in Teil 2 kommen wird
wir machen h natürlich weiter in Teil 2
mit einem höhenverstell beim Bett das
hier einfach so an die Decke fahren kann
es ist noch viel zu tun aber es wird
extrem geil und wenn ihr das sehen wollt
Abonniert den Kanal und dann sehen wir
uns be nächsten Mal wieder mach's gut